hey everyone I'm David Grinspoon I'm an
astrobiologist and I study how planets
get life and how they lose life and
welcome to the breakdown alright let's
start with a day after those are
Minuteman missiles
like a test sort of like a warning of
all the sort of post-disaster depictions
to me that this is in a way the most
actually frightening because it's a it's
a real thing that they tried to make a
realistic film oh but I remember
actually when that this was on I'm
watching this and I'm thinking where are
these people running to how is it gonna
really help I mean in theory you know
you get down in the basement and yeah
you know you can avoid the immediate
effects of fallout if you shelter in
place and don't breed that outside air
with the dust and if you get enough in a
basement or something you might let's
escape the radiation if you're not
literally in the blast zone
that's just I'm also looking at these
people and thinking yeah so what are you
gonna do a few days so there's the
immediate pulse of there's some these
short-lived radionuclides that if you
manage to shelter in place and not
breathe that air and breathe the falling
dust you know for for a few days and
then you get out you're much better off
that's the theory is that like there is
something you can do to stay alive
immediately and then you know maybe
maybe that's the only town that got
nuked and you can get to another one you
know but maybe not okay let's skip ahead
here
yeah boy that doesn't look like fun at
all the first thing I noticed was that
the electromagnetic pulse was depicted
if the glass doesn't get you and the
radiation doesn't get you the
electromagnetic pulse will make all our
electrical machines stop working within
a certain radius and then the explosion
itself is frightening ly convincing to
me you know I'm not sure about that
scene where all the people sort of turn
into skeletons but even that I think
that's an attempt to depict the fact
that there's these x-rays that are
pouring out of the thing that are frying
everybody and it's even conceivable that
you would see something like that in
your last you know microsecond of
consciousness before it happened to you
too
[Music]
yeah I think I think that is pretty well
depicted as far as I understand it first
of all there just be a completely
blinding flash of just radiation so
intense that everything would be white
in every direction even with your eyes
closed if that didn't blind you and you
were still able to see then yeah there'd
be this massive mushroom cloud which is
simply - you know the thermal pulse
immediately expanding this volume of air
which is low density because it's so hot
and it just it rises like a giant bubble
into the stratosphere and whenever you
release that much energy near the
surface of the planet you're gonna get
you know a bubble like that that just
inexorably rises up and forms that
mushroom I mean everything left would
would burn you know the aftermath of a
nuclear explosion in the city is a
firestorm massive massive amounts of
smoke and debris heading up into the
stratosphere and by the way that's why
you get a nuclear winter which is the
real main threat of the aftermath of the
nuclear war you know after all those
immediate effects and that is because of
all that smoke that ends up in the
stratosphere so those fire storms is
actually not from the nuclear bomb
itself but from the fires created all
the burning cities collectively they
make enough smoke that it circulates
around the planet in the stratosphere
and it's going to block out the Sun for
two years
again the best approach is to not let
this happen I mean the day after seems
very real to me it's got this kind of
heaviness to it that I still feel when I
see it even though I'm also going like
well that was the 80s and we've survived
till now so but that didn't happen
and now this is the fifth wave
okay so thereby at Lake the
broad-strokes of this seem realistic to
me
earthquakes are kind of short and
there's a sort of jolt and then they and
I've been in an earthquake and that
seemed pretty pretty well done and then
the idea that the wave comes that is
realistic in broad terms that's the
thing with the tsunami the same thing it
comes a while later but what I'm
wondering is the volume the concentrated
pulse of water from a lake I'm not
convinced that it works out in terms of
the size because the earthquake they
looked like they were experienced it
seemed like that was a major earthquake
but it wasn't like Krakatoa or the
ground level going up to bits and that
was yet that was a very very powerful
tsunami
[Music]
that's what I picture tsunami looking
like if you experience it it's you know
that's sort of the first rush of water
and then it more and more morning you
know we've seen footage in Japan and
Sendai which you know what's the first
really modern tsunami with like that
kind of footage of it crashing into
these urban areas and you know that I
looked pretty pretty realistic to me
let's check out Waterworld the polar ice
caps have melted covering the earth with
water those who survived have adapted to
a new world
so both probably and improbable the
polar ice caps can melt they have in the
past melted completely that are on their
way towards melting now and that does
raise sea level but it doesn't raise sea
level so much that the entire earth is
covered with water it raises the sea
level so much that the oceans are larger
and the landmass is comparatively
smaller you know many times actually
Earth has been ice-free in its history
you know not recently not since human
beings have been here so this is you
know a realistic threat in a possible
future where the earth would be ice-free
and there'd be a lot more ocean than
there is now and I would change VIPRE on
earth for sure but it's taken to an
extreme that that you would never see
happen interestingly in my field
astrobiology we consider the possibility
of life on a lot of other kinds of
planets that are like Earth but
different in some ways and there is a
kind of planet that we call water worlds
which is a planet like Earth but that it
initially just gets a lot more water so
that it never develops continents that
push up above the oceans it's completely
covered with water and there's a lot of
interesting question whether life could
evolve on such a planet so they're
probably our water worlds out there but
this is probably not a realistic future
earth okay let's skip ahead here
there's almost a familiarity to this
from thinking about astronauts in in a
space capsule and having to recycle all
their water and basically drink their
own piss although you know nicely
filtered and hopefully conditioned well
and I see him doing that at first I
think oh that makes sense he's keeping
his water and filtering it but the
difference between this and astronauts
and his space capsules that he's
surrounded by the water now you can't
drink it because of salt water but what
I'm wondering is is it really that much
easier to filter and recycle your piss
than to desalinate salt water in theory
you could do either it takes some energy
and some effort but I'm not sure about
that
maybe the pea would be easier to recycle
at times when it didn't he'd have to
manufacture fresh water either from the
ocean or from his own reused bodily
fluids and yeah the plant same thing
most plants can't handle salt water like
us they need fresh water so he did if he
wanted the company of his vegetable
companion he'd have to give it fresh
water too
alright let's fast-forward here through
another part of Waterworld
okay so here we see Kevin Costner
breathing underwater or at least Kevin
Costner's character which leads to the
question could people evolve gills I
don't see this happening naturally
biologically in other words the world
gets flooded some mutant humans are
gonna be born with gills and then they
survive better and give you know birth
to a sub race of humans with gills I
don't see evolution really working that
way
but in a way our closest analogies in
the ocean are the the whales and
dolphins and they didn't develop gills
what they developed was the ability to
hold their breath underwater and dive
and then they go to the surface to
breathe and they have lungs if it was
that easy to develop gills why didn't
dolfe ins and whales develop gills
uh-huh tell me that evolution yeah yeah
I think Kevin Costner should have a blow
be or not have not gills when they make
Waterworld - all right let's check out
12 monkeys five billion people died in
1996 and 1997 you believe 1996 is the
present then is that it
no 1996 is the past - listen to me I
think this is great uh Bruce Willis is
so good in this role you can see that
they have every reason to believe he's
nuts cuz he's spouting this this
ridiculous story about time travel I
love the way that setup and the
depiction of the end of the world in
this film again sort of frightening Lee
realistic in that the notion of a world
ending disaster because of some
biological agent that humans are
defenseless against you know it's not
necessarily an imminent threat but
there's a logic to it
and they dire prognostications about a
pestilence which he said would wipe out
humanity approximately 600 years
obviously this plague doomsday scenario
is considerably more compelling when
reality supports it with a virulent
disease whatever the infecting agent is
is something that's been evolving on
earth with us for billions of years than
is part of our you know biological
system is sort of out of whack but if
you have somebody deliberately
engineering something that there's no
defenses against there's potential that
that could happen that's what's so
unnerving about the fact that biological
engineering is sort of getting easier
and easier because it potentially puts
it in the hands of people with you know
less and less sort of institutional
allegiance you know people have counter
arguments about private why that
probably wouldn't happen and it's not
totally clear that it would but it's
it's certainly based on a premise that
has a realistic scientific rationale
[Music]
yeah so here we see New York City it's
obviously been overrun for a while
the plants are growing up in the streets
and through some of the buildings and
there's wildlife running through the
streets herds of deer this looks pretty
realistic to me I often wonder about
what's gonna happen to cities when and
if the humans disappear and and
sometimes you you'll be in a place a
part of New York are part of some other
city where for some reason it's been a
little block or a lot or something has
been abandoned and the city's still
there but it's kind of reverting the
forest slowly so you're gonna have the
grass growing tall and out of control
and other volunteer species moving in
and it's gonna you know go wild like
this it's gonna take longer for the
streets to become fields it's not gonna
happen overnight the pavement tastic
erode and sort of be worn down by
biology and have stuff grow up and you
know crack the pavement so it's gonna be
a number of years before the streets
look like fields it's hard to tell from
from this clip how many years it's
supposed to be all the cars are still
there in the streets looking pretty
pretty fresh they're not rusted out or
anything at least as I could see right
there I'm not sure the streets
themselves are gonna that quickly turn
into fields but they will eventually
okay let's skip ahead here
[Applause]
this is really scary and and I think
pretty well done in that one can imagine
if there's a really widespread disease
in a biological emergency in a you know
crowded modern city like this there
might be a need for for triage which is
that if you're gonna save anybody you
have have to not save some people it's
sort of a horrible thing to contemplate
and to depict here you know triage is a
real response to certain kinds of
emergencies and it's depicted in kind of
a brutal way that you can imagine if
figs were on the edge of chaos and the
authorities were struggling to maintain
control and this was the only way to
prevent everybody from dying that you
you could end up in a situation like
this the notion that we could lose whole
staple crops has some basis in reality
the food system is arguably more
vulnerable than it used to be because
we're moving more towards these sort of
monocultures and anytime you have a
monoculture
things that are you know genetically
similar forming the whole basis of a
food crop that makes it much more
vulnerable than it would be if it were
lots and lots of strains where a disease
a pathogen might infect one but not not
the neighbor's field which is a
different strain the specific thing I
think that's happening in interstellar
if I remember correctly is that the air
is changing the oxygen content is is
going down and I thought that particular
detail wasn't that realistic because
there are things you could imagine we
can do you know raising the co2 level
which we're doing now which if it
continues on the wrong course could
cause our climate apocalypse but
actually lowering the oxygen in the
atmosphere is not that easy and that's
not really a threat that would take you
know many many thousands of years even
if you stopped making new oxygen but the
notion that we've changed the planet in
some way that's making it harder to grow
food is certainly not not that hard to
imagine
to save the world we meant to leave it
the idea that someday people will try to
go live on planets outside our solar
system is not completely far-fetched
it's challenging because the stars are
so far away you can't get to them at an
ordinary rocket with in anything like a
human lifetime or a hundred human
lifetimes but science fiction is full of
people getting around that by inventing
fantasy physics you know Worf drop warp
drives or generation ships where you
have multiple human generations living
and in the descend the distant
descendants of the people that set out
other people that reach that other world
and it could happen someday the thing
that seems unrealistic to me about this
is that that's gonna be a response to us
messing up this planet it's like oh well
we need to go live on another one
because we screwed this one up and that
really seems like a cop-out if we are
ever able to go live on another planet
in any kind of numbers where we could
you know repopulate the human race and
survive it seems to me in some much more
far-off future than the much more
immediate problem with figuring out how
not to destroy Earth's climate and over
populate the planet and cause a mass
extinction and so if you ask me will we
ever go live on planets around other
stars I don't want to say never given
enough time that's something that could
happen but I don't see it as connected
to our current climate threats but
there's a kind of space industry space
exploration that is absolutely essential
to the project of saving the planet now
this particular thing where you've got
some hidden compound and people are
getting ready to launch off and try to
save themselves when everybody else dies
I could see people objecting to that you
know I might object to that and now next
up the Martian I have created 126 square
meters of soil
with every cubic meter of soil requires
4000 meters of water to be farmable so
the idea of farming on Mars is something
that's been studied a lot by people at
NASA and other agencies because we want
to be able to send people to Mars and we
want them to be able to live off the
land because there's no way you could
have any kind of a long-term presence on
Mars and have to bring all the food from
Earth just it's too expensive you're
launching too much mass so you want to
be able to grow your food there so it's
an interesting question could you grow
food in Martian soil and people are
trying that actually with Marcin Martian
simulant soils and it seems like
something we probably could solve
I think farming on Mars is realistic
eventually they'll be able to do it but
as I understand this story the premises
that they weren't actually planning on
doing this it was they're not at that
point yet where they sent up a colony
that had was really prepared to do this
and he's improvising and that seems like
he'd have to eat obviously very clever
but he'd also have to get really lucky
because there's gonna be a lot of
factors I mean there's a balance a lot
of things that can go awry I think it
might be harder to grow food on Mars
than is depicted in here but I also
think it is possible so using the
hydrazine from the rocket to separate
into majors in them and hydrogen and
then using hydrogen to make water I mean
that's realistic that he's worked out
the the author of this has worked out
the chemistry but I'm not sure the
biology part is gonna be as easy as he
as he thinks I think that humans will
eventually live on Mars but as a
post-apocalyptic way to survive on earth
it's it doesn't make much sense I mean
it's certainly nothing to hope for
because the idea that most people die
and then a few people go get to live on
Mars it's like yay let's think that's
kind of that's a pretty dismal scenario
but also the post-apocalyptic world is
probably not the best world in which to
innovate and have the resources to
figure out how to go live on Mars so I
think it's more likely than in a
thriving world then you have the the
scientific expertise and the resources
and the support back on earth
make the effort to go eventually build a
sustained society on Mars I think it's
gonna be harder to live on Mars than
people currently think I bet there's
gonna be failure before their success so
it's easier for me to imagine that
happening in a pre apocalyptic world
where there's the innovation and
Industry and support on earth to do the
trial and error there's gonna be needed
okay let's take a look at at Astra there
is this idea that you could build a
space elevator using a tether that was
attached to the earth and extended all
the way into orbit and the physics work
out if you had the right material that
had the right tensile strength it
couldn't be that heavy but it'd have to
be really strong and people want to make
it out of these you know new kinds of
like carbon nanofibers and things like
that that if if they come up with the
right material you could build a space
elevator and then the idea is you climb
up this rope or you essentially have
elevators that run up and down it and it
takes a lot less energy to get into
orbit than it does with a rocket so it
actually is physically realistic if you
could make the right materials people
are working on it
draw up seeing a power surge on seatpost
you're getting that if these guys are in
space they're not gonna hear anything
coming through the air there is no air
but they might hear that pulse the
electromagnetic pulse coming over their
radio sets and I imagine it would have
that kind of a wave sound that wobble
you know that I've never heard an
electromagnetic pulse but that that
seems reasonable to me that it could
have that kind of a wave sound piercing
through their headsets uncontrolled
release of antimatter could ultimately
threaten the stability of our entire
sources all life could be destroyed
antimatter is real and the notion that
you if you could isolate antimatter that
you could use it for space propulsion is
a real idea that at least theoretically
people have toyed with and of course on
Star Trek you've got the
matter/antimatter engines and that
that's riffing off of a real thing which
is that if antimatter encounters matter
it makes a tremendously powerful
explosion it would be a way to convert a
small amount of mass to a huge amount of
energy which is great if you want to
fuel a spacecraft you don't want to
bring a lot of mass but you want
something that's gonna keep on giving
you energy so that's it's a good idea
but we don't really know how to isolate
antimatter and we can make atoms of
antimatter individual atoms or even
small molecules and in the lab that
lasts for you know some ridiculous
nanosecond or a femtosecond but but the
idea that we could make a container full
of it and then take it on board a
spaceship it's still a science fiction
dream but I I see the premise here that
they've figured out how to do that and
that's how they're powering their
deep-space mission that that doesn't
seem impossible
I don't know what the specific thing
happening up near Neptune would be but
certainly one can imagine things that
would happen out near Neptune that would
affect the earth I mean in the galaxy
there are natural things that happen
that are powerful enough that if one
happened to put out super-powerful
flares
with the radiation that would sterilize
all life and things like that things
like that happen in the universe and if
you were the distance from Earth to
Neptune from one of those explosions or
flares or something you'd be in trouble
so if you imagine that there was
something that happened out in Neptune
that was that powerful then yeah or if
Earth would be in trouble
fast forward right here I don't see it
as unreasonable that you could have some
sort of a city or colony of people on
the moon it would you know obviously
take a lot of resources to build but
there are people that want to do such
things and there's nothing physically
impossible I mean you have to solve the
problems of you're gonna need energy
you're gonna need water you're going to
need food so there's nothing about
seeing this scale of act of human
activity and human habitation on the
moon that strikes me is physically
impossible it's just a matter of having
the money and the political will to
decide to do it okay now we have to
check out Wally
I love this movie wall-e is a great
great film and there are a few things
about it that are oddly realistic where
you're descending through that layer of
space debris that's a real thing that
can happen and it's a concern now that
we're putting so much stuff out there
that if you can get this cascade where
if satellites are out of control and
start to collide into each other that
creates more debris which creates more
collisions so it's it's an actual real
concern that you could end up with this
sort of impassable ring of space debris
that makes it harder to you know do
anything in orbit other than just like
it hit with the brief you know this
world it's it's kind of a worst-case
scenario you see the windmills and the
nuclear cooling tanks so it looks like
you're getting this quick glimpse of
this planet where they tried alternative
energy of various kinds to tried to save
themselves but they just got overrun in
their own garbage and then you know
basically lost it and you know it's a
cartoon so you can get away with a lot
but the the notion that we are
threatened by just making too much stuff
and it piling up is is kind of a
wonderful way to encapsulate one of our
real challenges now of humans in the
21st century realizing that the earth is
not infinite and that we can't just
throw stuff away because there is no
away there's only one planet you know
when we were much fewer in number and
didn't occupy the whole earth you could
throw stuff away in the world was sort
of functionally infinite but now we're
realizing it's finite and if we don't
deal with that then the end result is
wall-e
[Music]
so touching the romance between Wally
and and IVA I'm always moved you know I
it's very very hard to completely wipe
out life from a planet like Earth the
earth has been through some mass
extinctions before were you know really
horrible things happen and wipe out most
life but life is very very tenacious and
it's very ingrained in the planet so
most disasters that would wipe out human
civilization
or even the human race would not even
come close to wiping out the biosphere
the biosphere would sort of shrug us off
and keep going I mean it's happened over
and over again the biosphere is not
fragile
we're fragile our civilization is
fragile but you're not gonna wipe out
all life from Earth so yeah bugs
asteroids volcanoes all that stuff all
real threats maybe not completely
realistic as depicted in the movies
always but real real things to worry
about and then there's the you know the
biological disaster the genetic
engineering accident the mutant that
gets out of the lab and wipes out all
life and again there's a realistic
component to that worry episo-- so all
these things hollywood maybe runs off
with them in directions that make
scientists go you know not quite but
they're all real threats thanks for
listening to me talk about
post-apocalyptic worlds may we never see
any of them come true